- Yeah, absolutely, so
it was a little bit funny
because after, of
course, the Trump rally
about a month later,
the pandemic really hit
and not too long after that,
we had the George Floyd
incident in Minneapolis,
and after that critical race
theory really started taking
over my entire industry.
I had just been doing trainings
with organizations about
how to be better managers
and how to communicate
with each other
and interpersonal communication,
all that good stuff.
Well, critical
race theory came in
and took over absolutely
every single thing
and the results that
I've seen have just,
really, they've emphasized
why critical race theory is
not a good direction to go
and it's harming individuals,
it's harming team cohesion,
it's harming
organizational productivity
and yet organizations all
over the country are spending
thousands, tens of thousands,
some of them millions of
dollars on this training
that has absolutely no
foundational evidence
to support its effectiveness.
(upbeat music)
- It's Locals Week here
on The Rubin Report
and I'm doing a series
of many interviews
with creators on why they
decided to become less reliant
on big tech and instead
owned their content community
of livelihood with locals.com.
Joining me today is an
organizational therapist
and knitter turned
fearless political fighter.
Karlyn Borysenko, welcome
back to The Rubin Report.
- Thanks for having me.
- I am glad to have you back on
because although we're
gonna talk, obviously, a bit
about Locals and
why you're on there,
you really have become sort of
a fearless political fighter,
and a year ago, you weren't
in this game at all,
you were a simple private
person, a knitter,
and now look at you.
- Life is funny, Dave,
you never quite know what
it's gonna throw at you,
but it's been a wild
ride and I'm enjoying.
- Yeah, so for people that
don't know you, we'll link
to the full interview
that we did below.
And in effect you went
to a Trump rally thinking
you were gonna be
at a white supremacist
rally, and it turned out
that you were surrounded
by a lot of nice people
and now you've become a big
part of the WalkAway Campaign
and the rest of it.
How are you feeling about
the world at the moment?
- I mean, it is touch
and go, isn't it?
There are some days I'm like
we are all incredibly tombed
and there are some days
that, yeah, I just have
so much faith and
confidence in the direction
that we're going in.
I've been traveling
around the country
for the past couple of months,
doing WalkAway rallies all
over the place that I've gotten
to meet so many amazing people.
I've gotten to meet a
lot of conservatives,
a lot of Republicans, but also
a lot of people just like us
who have walked away from
the left and their energy,
and it's a different
vibe when you're
in the WalkAway community.
Everyone is happy,
it's like a burden has been
lifted off your shoulders
and I love it
- What's interesting to
me is that you're not just
like the average
person walking away,
but in many ways, your job
as an organizational
therapist is sort of tied
to why you're walking away.
Can you explain
that a little bit?
- Yeah, absolutely.
So it was a little bit funny
because after, of
course, the Trump rally
about a month later,
the pandemic really hit
and not too long after that,
we had the George Floyd
incident in Minneapolis
and after that critical race
theory really started taking
over my entire industry.
I had just been doing trainings
with organizations about
how to be better managers
and how to communicate
with each other
and interpersonal communication,
all that good stuff.
Well, critical
race theory came in
and took over absolutely
every single thing
and the results
that I've seen have just
really, they've emphasized
why critical race theory is
not a good direction to go in,
it's harming individuals,
it's harming team cohesion,
it's harming organizational
productivity,
and yet organizations all
over the country are spending
thousands, tens of thousands,
some of them millions of
dollars on this training
that has absolutely no
foundational evidence
to support its effectiveness.
And so that's really where
I've been focusing on
in the past couple
months is fighting back
against this monster
that has taken over
and really is
doing a lot of harm
to individuals and
to organizations
- And you've done a really
great job of sort of mapping
how you can stand up to
the mob and still survive
because you talk about it,
you've lost jobs
because of this,
but at the same time,
- Oh, yeah.
- you've got, I'm
guessing, thousands
of people reaching out
to you telling you,
"Oh, this stuff, this
critical race theory stuff,
it's leaking into
my organization,
how do I fight it
and everything else?"
- Yeah, that's absolutely true,
I've definitely been
canceled by clients,
but I've also gotten
clients in return.
And really where I'm at
right now is I just want
to help people understand
why this philosophy
is so dangerous
because it's one of
those things that...
One of the reasons
it is so dangerous is
because people
don't understand it,
organizations that
are implementing it
do not understand
exactly what it means.
And so if we can help
debunk what's going on
and really help
people approach it
in a more simple way
where you can just get
to the core issue of why
this stuff is dangerous,
then you can help them to
understand and then fight back
in their own lives.
- Yeah, so you
fighting back on this
and having jobs canceled and I
know all too well the stories
of what happens in a personal
life, and just earlier today
as we were tweeting like fools,
so the trolls were
going after you
and you said you were eating
your sushi lunch and smiling,
so I myself had a sushi lunch,
but that's sort of a good
segue to why you're on Locals,
because when we started
Locals, my initial idea was
I wanna find people who
are doing good work,
doing something valuable,
but could still be crushed
by big tech at any moment,
and the stuff that you're doing,
which is true and
decent and important,
the big tech people ain't that
thrilled with those ideas.
- No, they're not, it was funny
because right after I was
on your show the first time,
I started a Facebook
group, basically trying
to have civil
discourse among people
who disagreed with each other,
and that group is still
around and it's still going,
but almost immediately
upon starting that group
it became very clear
that Facebook was
going to censor it
and they would just
randomly delete things
that frankly, there
was no problem with it.
If someone was just
asking a question
that Facebook deemed
out of bounds,
they would just delete
it out of nowhere
and then I'd get a notification.
And so I was really freaking out
that one day I was
just gonna wake up
and this group
was gonna be gone.
And so you kind of reached
out to me and said,
"Well, bring it on to Locals
and you don't have to worry
about that anymore",
and so that's exactly
what I'm trying to do.
- And congratulations.
It's your community,
you can regulate it
or not regulated,
it has nothing to do with me,
it actually doesn't
really have anything to do
with the Locals people, we're
just giving you the tools
to do that.
So what are you doing on Locals
that you can't do as easily
when you're on Facebook
or Twitter or elsewhere?
- Well, I mean, what's great
about Locals is it's
like the adult community.
I mean, we were talking
about how we were dealing
with all these trolls
on Twitter today,
Twitter is not the
adult community,
you don't go on Twitter
to have adult conversation,
- Twitter is
the mental institution.
- you go on twitter to-
Exactly, and it can be
fun and all that stuff,
but if you wanna have
adult conversations,
you need an avenue to do that,
and even Facebook, it gets
really hard to do it on there,
but what I love about Locals is
that people are self-selecting
into this community,
there's that little barrier
of having to pay like
five bucks a month
to join the platform so that
you you tend to get people
that are much more interested
in actually having those
adult conversations,
and it's just so nice.
It's so calm and no one has
to worry about being canceled,
you don't have to worry
about being banned
at a moment's notice
because someone
at Twitter or Facebook doesn't
like what you're saying,
it's a relief is the
best way I can think
to describe Locals.
- Yeah, have you had any
crazy people in there?
I mean, has anyone decided
I'm gonna pay her money
so that I can be mean,
nobody does it, right?
- Well, I'm sure you just
gave them the idea to do that,
so thanks a lot for that.
- I made you a couple of bucks,
and then you have to decide
if you wanna keep them
'cause it's up to you.
- Exactly, but to
your point, no,
that absolutely
hasn't happened yet.
And in my Locals community, we
actually do weekly Zoom calls
with all of my Local supporters.
We actually get
on just like this
and we chat with each other.
And someone even said last
week, they were afraid,
they were like, "I don't know
if I'm gonna vote for Trump
and I'm afraid I'm gonna get
kicked out of the group",
I was like, "No, you're
not gonna get kicked out
of the group, just come in,
be a reasonable human being,
that's really all we ask for".
- It's interesting how
just a couple bucks will
kind of keep the
riffraff out, you know?
- Mmmh.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, and it just makes
it nicer for everyone.
It's not only nicer for me
as the person running
the community,
it's nicer for
everyone else there
and it allows people a way
to develop those genuine
human relationships,
and it's just been
really, really fantastic.
- Yeah, so when you're
fighting the mob,
I think I asked you a
version of this question
about a year ago when
we first sat down
or maybe it wasn't
even that long ago,
time is very strange these days,
- since COVID, it's like,
- Oh, I know.
- did that happened yesterday
or four years ago, I'm not sure,
but what is it about
you do you think
that lets you be brave in
these very strange times?
Because I think the reason
you've made a mark suddenly
is people are like,
"Oh, that girl is saying
what she thinks, and so many
people are afraid to do it",
some guy wrote a
book about that.
- (chuckles) He did, he did,
and we're actually
reading that book
in my community right now.
- Very, very serious.
- But I think what,
what for me is...
I mean, frankly what is lacking
among so many of the people
that we see out protesting
that all want these
safe spaces is I've had
to overcome a lot of
challenges in my life
from my family to different
bullies I've met in my life
and I think that when you
overcome challenges like that,
it sets you up to take on things
that are much more important.
So I think that I've developed
the resiliency from having,
to overcome things
throughout my life,
that I don't mind
standing up on a stage
and saying, "This
is what I think,
this is why I walked away
from the Democratic Party,
and some people
are gonna like it
and some people are
going to hate it,
and that's just the way it is",
but I also think that
there's something to being
in this every day, isn't there?
Is that when you have
the hate come at you,
it's a pattern and you can see
that no matter what you say,
no matter what you do,
the hate comes in
exactly the same way,
is incredibly predictable.
And so after a while you start
to realize it has nothing
to do with you at all.
It has to do with them
and where they're at
and the goals that they have
and trying to achieve those
goals by any means necessary.
So I can't take it personally,
it's not about me,
it's about them.
- Yeah, it's funny I had a tweet
that was catching fire today
and I had a very,
very minor typo in it
and I had like hundreds
of these trolls,
did you have a stroke,
are you retarded,
like stuff that's
much worse than that
and it's like, I don't
really care about that,
but it's like, wait a minute,
I thought you guys were
the tolerant, good people,
but maybe not as
tolerant and good
as you say you are
something like that.
Where do you sense
your community going,
what's the goal and how do you
stay out of the echo chamber?
I mean, one of the
things that I'm trying
to figure out with
my own community is
that people are paying a
couple of bucks to get in,
so you're self-selecting a
certain amount of people,
and I know for people like us,
we don't want it to be
just like minded people
and I love seeing people
interact with each other
and agree to disagree,
but how do you
guard against that?
- I really wanna have more
constructive discussion
and constructive
debate in my community.
One of the things
that I found is
that it is incredibly
hard to get people
who are not Trump supporters
or people on the right
to join the community.
We do have lefties in
there and I'm grateful
that they're in there
and I'm grateful
for their contribution, but I
really wanna see more of them.
So one of the things I wanna do
when I have a little downtime
after the election is
I wanna start doing
more constructive discussions,
I wanna start a debate club.
I actually wanna
have a debate club
where people get assigned
to their position
so they don't get
to choose them,
so sometimes they might have
to argue positions
they don't agree with,
just to understand
the other side.
And I think it's very important
for people to demonstrate
that they're capable of
having adult conversations
and walking away and being
like it's okay to disagree,
it's okay, we're
all gonna survive
- It's weird to be one
of the adults in the room
when there aren't as many
adults in the room, isn't it?
- Well, I'll tell you, if
you looked at my Twitter,
you would not think I was one
of the adults in the room,
but I do really try to
be in real life. (laughs)
- Well, I don't know what says
about the state of adulthood
like I'm making as many Star
Wars in GI Joe references
and yet somehow I'm
an adult in the room,
that's not 'cause of me,
that's mostly 'cause
of these people.
- Well, I mean,
that's a reflection
of where the people we're
fighting at are, aren't they?
Because if were the
adults in the room,
I mean, they're
the kindergarteners
in the room, aren't they?
- Yeah.
- All right, so one
more question for you
and then I want you to
pimp out your community
as hardcore as you can.
What do you see as the
path to getting out
of the mess that we
all feel like we're in,
the political mess, the cultural
mess, the societal mess,
do you see a path out of it?
- That really depends
on us, doesn't it?
Because we all have
to make the choice
about how we show
up every single day,
and if people don't want
to show up in an adult way,
then they're not going to,
if people don't wanna
have conversations
with people they disagree
with, they're not going to.
And I think my greatest
fear in this whole thing is
that it seems as though
there are so many people
that are just addicted to anger
and outrage and fighting, and
that is a physical addiction,
that is an addiction
just like cigarettes
or drugs or alcohol
and so in order to get
past that addiction,
they have to want
to overcome it,
and I worry that there
aren't enough people
that want to overcome it,
but again I'm on the
ground every single week
at WalkAway rallies
and I see that there are so
many people that are being kind,
and like truly kind, not
left is kind of kind,
but truly kind and empathetic
and understanding to each other
that it really does give
me hope that it's possible,
but we're gonna have to
see after the election.
I don't think we're gonna
get there before November,
but maybe afterwards.
- Well, I'm with you, of course.
And I guess I was sort
of like the original YLF,
the left guy, but
then when I see people
like you out there, I'm like,
"Oh, it's real, it's real
and it's happening with
other people and it's great".
So Karlyn pimp it out,
pimp out your Locals,
why should people join?
- Yeah, they should join
because it's just a group
of a regular people
that we get together,
we chat about topics that are
on our mind every single week.
We do it in the community,
we do it on Zoom,
we read books together,
it's super fun.
People can join at kb.locals.com
- That's kb.locals.com,
and I will see you out
there in the field.
If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead
of nonstop yelling, checkout
our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlists,
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.